اين نحن من الديمقراطيه احنا عايشين في
انهي مرحله ما الديمقراطيه دي عشان تتحقق
مراحل العالم العربي عنده مستويات مختلفه
لكن اجمالا كده احنا عايشين في انهي مرحله
من مراحل الديمقراطيه الاجابه وارجو ان لا
تكون صادمه احنا بنعيش في القرن 17 ليه
القرن ال 17 ده يقتدي ان انا احكي لكم قصه
اعتقد انها
بالغه الاهميه في فهم اوضاعنا من المحيط
الى الخليج القرن ال 17 ده كان قرن الدموي
جدا وهنتكلمنا عنه قبل كده لما كنا بنتكلم
عن التغير المناخي القرن 17 شاهد حروب
وثورات ومجاعات في مختلف دول العالم
واوروبا تحديدا شهدت احداث ماساويه الى
الدرجه التي دعت بعد المؤرخين لمحاوله
ايجاد تفسير لماذا كل هذا العنف والفوضى
في القرن ال17 والبعض ذهب الى ان السبب
الخفي هو وجود تغيرات مناخيه كبيره جدا
ادت الى مبيعات واضطرابات وبالتالي ثورات
وحروب
لكن هذا ليس موضوعنا موضوعنا ان كان في
كثير من الاضطرابات والحروب
في هذه الاضطرابات وفي هذه الاجواء ولد
فيلسوف انجليزي مهم اسمه توماس كل اللي
بيدرس فلسفه وبيدرس سياسه يعرفه جيدا هذا
الرجل ولد سنه
1588 وتوفي سنه
1679 يعني عاش تقريبا كل سنوات الفوضى
للقرن ال 17
وعاش تحديدا حرب الثلاثين عاما في اوروبا
وعاش ايضا الحرب الاهليه في انجلترا اللي
كانت ضحيه هاتين للحربين ملايين الانجليز
وملايين الاوروبيين فوضى عارمه
الراجل ده في هذه الفوضى كان مشغول مثل
كثير من مفكره عصره بالحل ما هو الحل ما
هو الحل الامثل للخروج من هذه الفوضى حتى
يعيش الانسان في امان
تمخض عقله عن فكره انه ان الحل الوحيد هو
وجود حكومه مركزيه قويه تتمتع بالسلطات
مطلقه على شعبها
وصاغ هذه النظريه في كتاب شهير اسمه
وما هو الليفايسن هو عباره عن وحش بحري
مخيف لغايه عنده موجود في الاساطير
الغربيه المتعدده وذكر في العهد القديم في
اكثر من موضع يعني ويشير الى وحش مخيف
لفايه باختصار عباره عن وحش هو كان بيقول
انه الحل في الدوله الوحش وما هي الدوله
الوحش هو بيقول ايه بيشرح توماس هوبس اللي
كان متاثر باجواء الفوضى التي سادت في
القرن ال 17 بيقول الانسان اللي بيعيش في
مجتمع بلا حكومه بيعيش فيما سماه هو
حاله الطبيعه الانسان بدون اي حكومه
وبيقول في هذه المجتمعات التي لا توجد
فيها حكومه بتبقى لا توجد فيها معايير
للصواب ولا الخطا واللي بيحكم الانسان في
هذه المجتمعات هي غرائز الانسان الشريره
الطماعه وان الانسان بيسعى في هذا المجتمع
الذي لا توجد فيه حكومه لمحاوله اخذ ما
يستطيع ان ياخذه بالقوه وهو مستعد
للسطر على ما يريد لقتل الاخرين وطبعا
الاخرين مستعدين لقتله ان استطاعوا
وبالتالي في حاله من الفوضى وفي حاله من
الحرب الدائمه حرب من حرب الجميع ضد
الجميع غرف اول اجانست اول
وانه بيعتقد انه لا يوجد حل للخروج من هذه
الحرب الدائمه الا اذا عقد المجتمع او وقع
المجتمع على عقد اجتماعي سوشل كانتراكت
ايه السوشيال كونتراكت ده طبعا العقد
الاجتماعي ده عقد وهمي كده افتراضي انه
المواطنين هيوقروا عقدا في هذا العقد
الافتراضي هيتنازلوا فيه عن حرياتهم
وحقوقهم الى حاكم ينصبوه يكون قادرا على
اقامه الدوله الوحش
لفايثان يكون وظيفه الحاكم اللي سماه او
السيد
يتمتع بسلطات مطلقه
في مقابل ان يوفر للناس حق الحياه والامن
فقط طيب العقد ده من يوقعه ده اتفاق بين
المجتمع من يعيش في المجتمع بينهم بين
بعضهم البعض وليس بينهم وبين الحاكم ليه
مش بينهم وبين الحاكم لانه يرى ان الحاكم
فوق كل السلطات وفوق كل القوانين هو لا
يخضع لاي سلطات ولا اي قوانين هو فوق كل
القوانين ارادته قانون ووفقا لتوماس هوبس
هو يرى ان الحاكم لا يجب ان يشاركه في
السلطه لا برلمان ولا احزاب ولا قضاء ولا
اي شيء لماذا لانه لو شاركوا برلمان ويعني
مؤسسات اخرى سوف تنتقص من صلاحياته
وبالتالي سوف تحد من قدرته على السيطره
على الفوضى التي تعم المجتمع ان كان بلا
حكومه طبعا تذكروا ان الرجل كان متاثرا
بتجربه الحرب الاهليه في بريطانيا اللي
بدات سنه 1600 اظن 42 واستمرت سنه
1651,651 ده السنه اللي كتب فيها كتابه
الدوله الوحش او لفيثان
لما كان في صراع ما بين الملك وما بين
البرلمان وادى الى حرب اهليه شملت معظم
دول بريطانيا العظمى وبالتالي يعني كانت
في فوضى عارمه
وبيعتقد انه هذا الملك او السفره الحاكم
يتمتع بسلطات مطلقه ولا يمكن طبعا الدوله
ان تسقط لان لا يوجد من يهدد الدوله
المواطنين خاضعين تماما للحاكم لا توجد اي
مؤسسات يمكن ان تنازعوا السلطه فقط يصبح
العقد لاغيا بين الرعيته وبين الحاكم في
حاله فشل السفر او الحاكم او الملك في انه
يحفظ حق الحياه او الامن للمواطنين اما ما
دام يحافظ على حقوق الحياه وعلى الامن
فيظل قائما ويتمتع بصلاحيات كامله القاعه
كامله من هذا الشعب
دي كانت نظريه توماس هوبس طبعا توماس هوبس
للمره التانيه والتالته هو كان ابن عصره
ابن الفوضى العارمه التي ضربت انجلترا
وضربت كثير من دول اوروبا كان يرى ان
الامل الوحيد للخروج من الحياه الطبيعيه
اللي هو يراها سيئه جدا ويعني فوضويه
ودمويه وان الانسان بيعيش فيها زي ما قال
بالظبط كده حياه منعزله وفقيره وبغيضه
وحشيه قصيره لانه بيقتل علشان الاخرين
يسطوا على امواله انه الحاكم يكون صاحب
سلطات مطلقه
توماس هوبس
الدوله الوحش جاء بعدها مفكرين اخرين
اختلفوا معهم مثلا جاء بعده بسنوات قليله
اصلا في حياته جون لوك اللي المواطن برضو
الفيلسوف البريطاني قال لا يجب ان يكون
هناك عقد اجتماعي بين الناس وبين الملك
وهم بيدوروا على صيغ مختلفه لانسب حكومه
تناسب المجتمعات اللي هي بتعاني دي قال لا
هيبقى العقد لكن العقد ده هيوقع ما بين
شعب او ما بين مواطنين وما بين حاكم هناك
التزامات على الحاكم وهناك حقوق للمحكومين
وانه اي حاكم لابد ان اثناء ان يتم هذا
العقد بين الطرفين الحاكم عنده مسؤوليات
ان يحفظ حقوق الناس مش بس حق الحياه حق
الحياه والحريات العامه
الامور الى ان صارت الديمقراطيه الغربيه
كما نرح الان طب انا بحكي القصه الطويله
دي كلها ليه لان من يتامل الدول العربيه
يجد ان احنا عايشين في النصف الاول من
القرن 17 لما بنتكلم عن تطور الديمقراطيات
احنا واقفين عند مرحله توماس حبس الراجل
الذي كان يدعو الى اقامه دوله
بالغه التسلط والشموليه فقط في مقابل
الامن والامان وحق الحياه
توماس هوبس كان ابن عصره تجاوز
تجاوزت افكاره في اوروبا تجاوز الزمن
افكاره وجاء يعني اخرين لكن احنا واقفين
عند المرحله دي تعال كده تامل من المحيط
الى الخليج هتجد ان احنا قدام يعني الوضع
الاتي دول تعتبر محظوظه لانها لا تعرف
الفوضى
زي مين هتجد مثلا انت عندك بلد زي مصر بلد
زي المغرب هتجه الى حد كبير بلد زي
الجزائر وطبعا دول الخليج الاردن الى اخره
لكن القسم المشترك بين الدول ديت اللي
عندها ظروف مختلفه هي فكره الدوله الوحش
الدوله الوحش ديت مش اساءه مش شتيمه ولكن
فكره الدوله القويه جدا اللي هي بيخضع لها
المواطنين بالسمع والطاعه الكامله في
مقابل الحفاظ على حقوق اساسيه طبعا احنا
مش بنتكلم على كلام توماس حبس فقط حق
الحياه
وسلطات يعني مطلقه تماما كما كان القرن في
السابع عشر في 17 ولكن شيء يشبه ذلك لانه
العقد ده بين المواطنين وبين الحاكم
الحقيقه بيخول للحاكم السلطات شبه مطلقه
في العالم العربي والهدف الاساسي ان ينجو
مواطني هذه الدول من الفوضى التي عاشها
مؤخرا بعد ثورات الربيع العربي الامن
الاستقرار في مقابل يعني الفوضى اللي
العالم كله او المواطنين منه دي الدول
المحظوظه طب ايه الدول الغير المحظوظه
الدول الغير محظوظه التي لم تتمكن اساسا
من اقامه الدوله الوحش يعني مثلا ايه
مشكله لبنان لبنان دلوقتي
ولبنان اثناء الحرب الاهليه الثانيه من
1975 لسنه 90 ولبنان منذ تاسيسه وتحديدا
اثناء الحرب او ما يسمى بالحرب الاهليه
الاولى سنه 1958 مشكلتها عدم وجود الدوله
بالاساس دوله ضعيفه جدا ليس لديها الدوله
التي يمكن ان نسميها
وبالتالي لما تيجي تشوف مشكله لبنان
دلوقتي ان احنا تقريبا لبنان بيعيش ما
سماه والتوم الخبز بستيت اوف حاله الطبيعه
حيث الكل في حرب ضد الكل
والامل من وجهه نظر توماس حبس للابنانيين
هو وجود دوله قويه تستطيع ان تجمع السلاح
من كل هؤلاء وتبسط سيطرتها الوضع في ليبيا
نفس القصه لا يوجد الدوله
لفيثان الدوله الوحش القادره على ان هي
تجمع السلاح وتفرض الامن على الجميع القصه
تشبه كذلك الاوضاع في اليمن
وهكذا الوضع في العراق يعني تقدر برضه
تقدر
توصفه بانه مشكله العراقيين هو عدم وجود
دوله قادره على بسط الامن والسياده ما
يعني ان احنا في العالم العربي
المحظوظ هو الذي يعيش في مرحله من حيث
الديمقراطيه في النصف الاول من القرن ال17
وغير المحظوظ هو من لم يصل اساسا الى هذه
المرحله ويعيش في مرحله ما يسمى بالحاله
الطبيعيه او استيتوفن هيتشر لتوماس حبس
توماس حبس هو فيلسوف هذه المرحله افكاره
بتعبر الى حد كبير عن اوضاع العالم العربي